[Musique]
tu es un dur de Winterfell
tu sais que nos mots l'hiver arrive
tu es né pendant le long été même tu
as été sur n'importe quoi d'autre mais maintenant l'
hiver arrive vraiment et en hiver
nous devons nous protéger prendre soin les uns des
autres celui-ci  ça va être long et des
choses sombres viendront avec ça
le mur arrive Ned je ne sais pas quand je
ne sais pas qui se battra qui
arrive le pouvoir est une chose curieuse il
réside là où les hommes croient qu'il réside
veulent un truc une ombre  sur le mur et un
très petit homme peut projeter une très grande
ombre
ce que vous voyez est un nain je suis
né paysan ils auraient pu me laisser
mourir dans les bois rires je suis né un
Lannister de Casterly Rock vous appréciez le
jeu  Je le fais et tu le joues bien un bon
roi sait quand économiser ses forces et
quand détruire ses ennemis tout le monde qui
n'est pas nous est-ce que tu es en présence
de Daenerys Stormborn de la maison Targaryen
reine des Andals et des premiers hommes
Khaleesi  du grand brise-mer d'herbe
de chai  ns et mère des dragons tu
as bien revendiquer un titre un droit d'aînesse mais
tu as quelque chose de plus que ça tu
as un coeur doux il serait non seulement
respecté et craint tu serais aimé
je t'offre un choix plier le genou et
me rejoindre
nous conduirons le monde dans un endroit meilleur
que celui où nous l'avons trouvé ou refusons et mourrons,
vérifiez salut
cette guerre des cinq rois ne signifie rien la
vraie guerre se trouve au nord Starks a
occupé le mur pendant des milliers d'années
et vous êtes un dur que vous n'auriez peut-être pas
mon nom au-delà de mon sang je m'appelle Jon
Snow je suis Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch nous ne sommes pas amis
ce n'est pas une question d'amitié c'est
une question de survie la longue nuit arrive
et les morts
viennent avec elle les marcheurs blancs sont réels
la nuit où King est réel, j'ai vu
s'ils franchissaient le mur et que nous nous disputions
entre nous, nous avons terminé
Lord Tyrion me dit qu'un million de personnes
vivent dans cette ville, ils sont sur le point de
devenir un million de soldats de plus dans l'
armée  des morts
viens avec moi B  randon Stark je
t'ai attendu avant de partir tu
dois apprendre et tout ce que
je peux voir des choses qui se passent dans le passé
je peux voir des choses se passer maintenant partout dans
le monde qui es-tu
je suis et où es-tu rentré
Westeros le  la plus jeune fille d'un
grand seigneur c'est parce que je veux vraiment
n'être personne non une fille n'est pas prête à
devenir personne mais elle est prête à devenir
quelqu'un d'autre
en hiver nous devons nous protéger prendre soin les
uns des autres
Lannister Baratheon arrête Tyrell
ça ne fera que parler  une roue
celui-ci parle et celui-là est dessus
et moi dessus tourne en écrasant ceux par
terre
je ne vais pas arrêter la roue je
vais casser la roue
quand tu joues au jeu des trônes tu
gagnes
mort il y a  pas de terrain d'entente
deadman dragon queen
[Musique]
il n'y a qu'une seule guerre qui compte
c'est ici
Oh dit visite fan Lucy
toi